we ask for your protection over  house-call and we pray that we will be  kept from harm throughout the night  [Music]  is he dead no get him inside quick  you're a most unwelcome visitor and we  do not propose to entertain you you'll  find them easily used you won't be here  long enough for that don't you end up in  this place why are you so interested in  me why did my ear strengthen I'm just  trying to give them what they need to  survive in these times if you could have  anything in the world what would it be  to be taken far away from here  go with me he seems to be a sensitive  person does he  it seems the enemy it's not what we  believe I hope you like apple pie is  that my recipe it is I need rags  I need chloroform go to the smokehouse  get the saw now  bring me the anatomy book can I get you  anything  give me the key you know what control  [Music]  you  you